but now a bit of positive news China has
reported zero locally transmitted cases
for the third straight day
authorities say all 41 of the new
confirmed cases were brought in from
overseas
after weeks of fighting the disease with
tough measures China is now sharing its
experience with the rest of the world
and providing much-needed supplies
from being at the receiving end of
coronavirus aid from other nations to
helping the rest of the world battle the
disease China has its domestic outbreak
largely under control and is now
supplying millions of mosques and other
badly needed items to struggling
governments around the globe Beijing
hopes the aid will help build political
ties and defuse criticism that it was
too slow in tackling the outbreak for
people in China life has slowly been
returning to something approaching
normality though many restaurants and
shops are still carrying out temperature
checks on customers in the capital
Beijing shoppers voiced confidence in
government measures to reduce imported
cases by isolating arrivals from abroad
so many people here I don't feel so
worried because right now their systemic
approach to crime keening the imported
cases of coronavirus and those who have
come back from abroad so I'm not that
worried everyone is being very vigilant
about those returning from overseas we
absolutely must not let our guard down
we cannot allow rebound in case numbers
and so put to waste the achievements
we've made and the battles with won as
the pandemic engulfs the rest of the
world seems like this offer a glimpse of
how life can recover from the crisis
let's go to China now correspondent
Fabien Kretschmer is standing by for us
he is in Beijing Fabien it sounds like
little by little Beijing and maybe the
entire country starting to return to
normal is that fair to say yeah that's
fair to say I would call it not normal
but maybe the new normal I mean the
streets are filled by people now I mean
it's not as crowded as it used to be but
let's say 60 70 percent at least people
are also brave enough to take the subway
they go to restaurants the shops are
closing really you can see the Capitol
here are waking up like every day a
little
more but of course you have strict rules
in restaurants for example they are only
allowed to take half of the customers
etc and most people are still wearing
face masks so they are cautious but yes
they are really feeling more safe now
yeah we can see in those pictures I mean
pretty much everyone's still wearing a
face mask because theoretically there
are still risks here right I mean we we
heard there are still cases coming in
from outside could all this increase
movement lead to another outbreak I mean
that's a dilemma right now China is
becoming or turning into a virus free
zone as long as they are keeping the
restrictions up tight and that the
restrictions are mostly for people
coming from outside they have to go into
centralized Carentan stations that's
really serious but as long as they keep
this rule intact
yes a China could become basically virus
free but as long as they relax or loosen
up loosen up this regulations of course
the virus would spread immediately
Fabian Kretchman reporting in Beijing
where people beginning to come out of
hibernation there thank you very much